mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
in square a b c d
e is the midpoint of a d
construct a circle between the three
points e b and c
which shape has the larger perimeter the
square or the circle
i saw this problem on map stack exchange
it was described as a surprisingly hard
problem for high school students
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i'm going to present three different
ways to solve this problem
let's get started with the intersecting
chords theorem
to begin we'll construct the
perpendicular bisector of the top side
of the square
since point e this top point is tangent
to the circle this perpendicular
bisector is a diameter of the circle
it also bisects the bottom side of the
square
so if this length is equal to y
this length will also be equal to y and
the entire side of the square will be
equal to 2y
if we write r for the radius of the
circle then 2r is the diameter of the
circle and the remaining distance on the
diameter is equal to 2r minus 2y
now we can use the intersecting chords
theorem
we must have 2y multiplied by 2r minus
2y
is equal to y multiplied by y
let's simplify this equation
we'll first distribute and then we'll
group like terms
we'll then factor y
and we can then solve this equation
y is either equal to zero or y is equal
to four-fifths r
since we want y to be a positive value
so the square side has a positive length
we reject y is equal to zero
therefore y is equal to four-fifths r
which means r is equal to five over four
y
let's now calculate the square's
perimeter
a side to the square is equal to two y
which means the perimeter is equal to
four multiplied by 2y which is equal to
8y
now let's calculate the circle's
perimeter or its circumference
that'll be equal to 2 pi r now r is
equal to 5 over 4 multiplied by y
which means 2 pi r is equal to 5 pi over
2 multiplied by y
and this is approximately equal to 7.85
y which is definitely less than 8y
therefore the square has the larger
perimeter
now let's proceed to the next method
which uses a property of right triangles
we'll proceed like method one where we
have the perpendicular bisector
notice this will also be perpendicular
on this side of the square
we'll label the lengths as before
and now if this is the center of the
circle
this length will be equal to r
and this length will also be a radius of
the circle
now if this distance is equal to x
what must x be equal to
well we want the entire side of the
square to be equal to 2y
therefore we must have x plus r is equal
to 2y which means x is equal to 2y minus
r
we now consider this right triangle by
the gogu theorem we have two y minus r
of the quantity squared plus y squared
is equal to r squared
we can then simplify this equation and
just like before we end up with a very
similar equation
we have two possibilities and we reject
y is equal to zero and this proceeds
just like before where we calculate the
perimeter of the square and the circle
and we're going to get that the square's
perimeter is going to be larger than the
circle's perimeter
now onto method 3 using similar
triangles
let's construct the following chords of
the circle
we have this chord and this chord
now this entire triangle will have an
angle that's inscribed in a semi-circle
therefore this is a right angle
now that means this is an altitude on
the hypotenuse of this right triangle
therefore it divides this right triangle
into two similar triangles
this is the larger right triangle and it
has a ratio of the short leg to its long
leg equal to one over two that's y over
two y
this will be similar to this right
triangle which must have the same ratio
in this triangle the longer leg is equal
to y so the shorter leg must be equal to
y over two to get a ratio of one over
two
we now have r as the radius which means
that two r is equal to two y plus y over
two
we then have r is equal to five over
four y
which means just as before we calculate
the squares perimeter and the circle's
perimeter and we're going to get that
the squares perimeter is larger
i know there are many other ways to
solve this problem it's a really fun one
do check out the thread on matte stack
exchange and you can share your
solutions over there
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you